in the early 60s when the efficient
market hypothesis were developed the
basic idea there was just because you'd
like a company doesn't mean you invest
in the company's stock okay now why is
that well the reason is that everybody
else already knows but that's a good
company and they already would have
invested and that there and the
everybody's desired to invest with drive
the stock price up right to what
economists like to call the fair market
value of the company given all the
information of how good the company is
and so there the great insight there is
the return that you get investing in a
company is determined by the riskiness
of a company not how good the company is
so when this hypothesis was developed
and it was a pretty radical hypothesis
at the time because before that people
were not even saying no no good
companies is a good investment persons
responsible for the efficient market
hypothesis you Jean farmer he turned
around and said I'm going to show you
why the how powerful this hypothesis is
I'm going to show you the very people
who claim they can pick stocks can't and
the way I'm going to show you this is
I'm going to look at the return of
mutual fund managers so managers of
actively managed mutual funds who
advertise they could pick stocks and
what he found was the return of those
mutual funds in particular the return to
investors in those mutual funds was no
different than throwing darts at the
stock market and from then onwards
people began we had this impression that
mutual fund managers do no better than
monkeys and it's called you know monkey
investing is often a name for this
well there are a couple things wrong the
first thing that strikes you as odd
about this view of the world that all
these mutual fund managers are being
paid and yet have no skill is it
violates the most important principle of
microeconomics when an undergraduate
steps into his microeconomics lecture
for the first time the first thing that
hit undergraduate learns is something
called rents and competition the idea
being that only people with a skill in
short supply or able to make economic
rents in other ways they are able to
make money if you don't have a skill in
short supply
then everybody competes with you and
there are no reigns right so look at
mutual fund managers what we see will we
see mutual fund managers who amongst the
most highly paid members of society
making money without having any skill it
be equivalent to saying anybody could
become a mutual fund manager or maybe
you just have to be lucky and you become
a mutual fund manager you have no
particular skill and you earn tons of
money it just seems odd ok that's the
first problem
the second problem is more fundamental
let's go back to the the good companies
the reason good companies are not good
investments is again this idea of
competition everybody knows it's a good
company everybody invests that drives
the stock price on the same principle
can be applied to mutual funds so we
have a mutual fund which everybody
thinks has a very skilled manager and as
a result this mutual fund is making what
we call a positive alpha so what I mean
by positive alpha is you're beating the
market so alpha is the measure of how
much you're beating the market PI so pi
so the what we find is the mutual fund
has a cost of alpha well everybody's
going to want to invest in that mutual
fund
everybody wants a positive alpha and so
you get an inflow of capital into the
fund now the more capital a manager has
to manage the harder it is for the
manager to beat the market simple
intuition is when you the bigger the
trade you have
the more you move the price against you
when you go to trade and so as the
capital flows in the alpha of the
manager goes down funds will keep
flowing in until what happens people no
longer want to invest when do they no
longer want to invest when the return
they get and the mutual fund is the same
as they are next best alternative
investment opportunity in other words
the market so when the return of the
mutual fund hits the return of the
market and the alpha zero people stop
invest now let's think about what this
means it means that no matter the return
the manager makes in the market doesn't
measure his skill level up to now will
be used as the return to investors to
measure the skill the manager what if we
now instead used the amount of money the
manager makes to measure the skill of
manager now that actually isn't the
whole story because you could imagine
that not only does the manager make
money for himself but maybe out of the
goodness of his heart he also makes
money for investors alternatively maybe
the managers are charlatans and he has
no skill but he takes money from
investors so what does it mean to make
money for investors it means that you
provide a positive alpha to investors
and what does it mean take money from
investors it means you have and the
investors earn a negative alpha they
invest in the mutual fund and the return
of the mutual fund is less than the
return they could have got in the market
portfolio so if we really want to
measure the math skill the marriage what
we have to measure is the total amount
of money the manager makes for himself
plus any money he makes for investors or
if he or if he takes money from
investors we subtract that so what is
that that turns out to be the fee that
he makes plus the alpha multiplied by
the total assets under management or
another way of saying the same thing the
gross alpha which is the alpha before
fees times the size of the fund if we
use that measure to measure managerially
a birdie what do we find
what you find is the average mutual fund
manager is highly skilled the average
mutual fund manager adds approximately
two million dollars a year managing a
fact if mutual fund managers throwing
darts and picking stocks they're
obviously getting some mutual fund
managers that by pure luck would have
picked good stocks so the question is if
you just look at the data you're always
going to find skilled managers or
managers that have done well the
question is how do we know if that skill
the way we know that that skill is we
take the marriages that have done well
in one year and we look how they do in
the following year because if you're
just lucky in one year there's no reason
why you're going to be lucky again in
the next year and so if it's just luck
that's driving performance what you
should find is it will not be persistent
what you find is is if you use this
measure of skill we can predict
performance out as long as ten years
that's highly unlikely to be generated
by luck and so the most logical
explanation is that managers themselves
have skill and that skill is clearly
persistent
you